[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about wow
we got aj back
[Applause]
it's been such a long time the last time
i saw you was in toronto right for the
basketball oh yeah
that's true i feel like we see each
other probably every basketball
every basketball we saw we saw him after
toronto we did
in northern california's win for the bay
area basketball
game oh that's funny that's the last
time i saw you yeah the other basketball
game
was that after toronto damn how many
basketball games have we played
i know we played it but we played a
soccer tournament yeah
[Music]
invited me but i don't know why simo
didn't uh
drama i had this i had just
that's what happened to me because i saw
bart go and i was like
yeah yeah a lot of people are salty what
a [ __ ] cheerleader dude
just because i suck at basketball
doesn't mean i can't be useful
you got spirit yes you do yeah but i
don't like throwing the ball
i get nervous they i mean last time when
you were the coach
or what were you the you were like a
player coach mc you're the mc coach
yeah yeah mc coach yeah me and will paco
that was really fun
that was a fun game i mean i feel like
it's cool because i also suck at
basketball
no you don't i do you're better than me
i mean
i made one three in the last like couple
games that's [ __ ] good i mean
but you're like hammering on the inside
i just like to hurt people
yeah yeah you're right he's a wall i
don't even care if i have the ball or
not
i just want to go in there just like oh
something when's the last time i saw
everyone here though
i saw more recently than you guys at
linda shoot oh yeah
i was the one holding up all the shitty
lights yeah yeah and uh that was only a
couple months ago
no well i mean covet times now it's it's
been like
it felt like two years ago honestly man
seven months
i haven't been here and i mean someone
can look it up
eight years at least no one's gonna look
it up yeah nine ten years there's about
you guys have thousands of jk news
videos yeah it's hard to eat find
anything
you know what i missed from back in
those days are the remember those like
asian youtube like variety shows
i know so like shows yeah so i couldn't
wait till like where i know i'm gonna
see a couple musicians i'm gonna see a
couple dancers a couple of other youtube
comedians
and i couldn't wait to see like oh who's
gonna be there oh they're gonna be in
minnesota [ __ ] yeah and it's like
we all kind of live in california but we
don't really see each other in
california we should see each other like
yeah the show's funny only when you guys
are somewhere else yeah
it was so weird i feel you i mean when
those
times kind of were over and everyone was
just doing their own thing
you know it's because like everyone's
booking rate got expensive
the rates exactly greedy ass youtubers
man
they couldn't afford us anymore yeah
everyone they could only afford one
instead of like five or six
i know because the last show i played
with y'all i think you know joseph vince
was a part of it that was here in
california i think
and what show was that one some benefit
charity show
and always some better i just remember
the green room and
you know there's always that one fan who
just kept bugging us yeah because he's
like getting too much in our in our
space
yeah yeah yeah which we appreciate this
[ __ ]
i wish there was some six weeks i'll
just be like bro you [ __ ]
get out i just remember that one guy
though because he was bugging my sister
too
and like you know kat vadar and stuff we
all got a tablet
yeah yeah you know it was that show back
in the day
wait was it at a church i feel like it
must have been at a church our green
room was like
not a real green room it was like
confession stan
wait okay i remember i remember there
was this
thirst fool right he was so thirsty he
wasn't even i don't think he was a real
fan what he was trying to do
was just clout chase right yeah and then
he found out where we were [ __ ]
eating afterwards
he came with this came through camera
crew oh my god
came with his own camera crew right and
then he's like hey
uh i don't want to bother you guys but
can i like take a picture and then we're
just like all right cool right
and this fool with this professional
photographer
like acted like he was eating food with
the
sitting down on the table and then like
getting these [ __ ] action shots and i
was like is this [ __ ] happening right
now bro
was it he was running a vlog or
something huh he was writing a vlog
or i don't know if they did vlogs back
then but i felt like
he was just you know it's like that guy
that
always like comes up to you and tries to
like collaborate immediately you don't
even know who the [ __ ] you leave
that's the thing he's like giving you a
business card he's all like yo man we
got to do big things together man and
it's like
who are you what the [ __ ] yeah can we at
least like
have lunch i got a studio in my car i
want to record some tracks
yeah i feel like maybe it was a little
newer to us back then but
i i i'm better at navigating the awkward
and the thirsty pants i feel like that
doesn't happen as much anymore because
i'm not
um i'm forgotten so um
not just getting back then was just
crazy i think everyone was just trying
to like figure [ __ ] out
but now people are more respectful like
at meeting greets i feel like back then
it was weirder and crazier and then now
it seems like
people are just more socially
intelligent i don't know
yeah i feel that you know what i like to
call that time too and
this comes from maybe a high horse type
place
but um like spit it down 2012 a little
bit is like kind of our asian american
youtube renaissance area you know where
we're playing
live for the people our all of our
youtube views
were like really great you know at the
same time there's like the subscriber
charts we're seeing each other rise
yeah so i really missed that time and
too that was pretty cool because before
um youtube was major right or like
like the way it is now there wasn't
really a platform for asians
so like all of the creative we had the
idea that asians couldn't be creative
like that was just in our minds because
we didn't see them in hollywood or
anything
maybe like bobby lee mark margaret show
and a few just a handful of asians right
and then gilbert godfrey oh god and
cooper garciago right
but what's he do he's half chinese oh i
didn't know that but when youtube came
to play what ended up happening was like
we started seeing
hella talented as asian peoples and we
were and
when we did the shows we all kind of
connected so i think that was
the birth of our entertainment community
totally but now it's different because
we all have access to hollywood like
crazy rich asians and authors
so but it was first built on yeah the
beginning youtube
yeah for sure do you think we deserve
royalties
[Laughter]
of course
it's just like i feel like if that time
we had the type of access we had to like
brands
and big companies who would like maybe
help fund
these dreams that we had in the
beginning you know i mean you all have
an office and all that stuff and you all
started
pretty early in we got two offices i
mean you know we wasted a lot of money
like a lot of money you like four
if you count all the other ones all
right right yeah imagine if if
we had gotten you know maybe record
labels to invest in us
at an earlier time i mean specifically i
blame those i blame the other
youtubers that screwed it all up for you
guys because remember like back then and
even now like there's there's these
youtubers that get these amazing
opportunities and then they just
kill it for the rest of the year oh yeah
because they say logan paul right now
yeah you know maybe yeah let's be
specific
there's a lot of people no yeah i feel
like definitely after maybe 2012 2013
when we're all trying to
do our own thing then uh like
specifically non-asian creators and
stuff
you see them kind of getting similar
view counts subscribers but they're also
being funneled with
money probably and brand deals oh yeah
dude
that was their image and all that stuff
when we went to a
youtube like it was like we went to
youtube headquarters because they wanted
to
um help out the diverse group right like
they
remember that focus group that that we
were part of yeah and
so they were asking all these questions
like hey do you guys feel like
included and welcomed and all that and
then like
a lot of other minorities there like
we're just kind of like
yeah you know like um it's not fair that
like
white people get all these sponsorships
and we don't and we're not
marketable and i'm like you know what
instead of like asking us how we feel
tell us how we can win
yeah i was like why is it
that they are more marketable is it
because
the population is higher so then you
want
um someone who's more relatable that's
fine i don't mind
but make it so that your ads are more
targeted toward
specific groups then so then if i'm if i
can represent
you know the asian entertainment or
whatever then the ads are going there or
whatever
and then teach us how to win within the
system instead of just asking us like
hey do we feel included he doesn't
[ __ ] do [ __ ]
and then everyone's like yeah and i'm
like those are the real answers we want
and i'm like all right so uh did they
help us or do anything afterwards [ __ ]
no why
why it doesn't [ __ ] change ways it's
a [ __ ] waste man
all these focus groups we want to change
it and make it more diverse
i feel you a lot of companies will
probably just have like
the the key people of color in in the
meeting just to say that they
yeah they did ask you know instead of
really making that
oh yeah but i for me i was like okay
whatever as long as we have this
opportunity of youtube or access to
people
i'm already grateful enough sure we
never had it
like think about our parents generation
or even our older brothers right like
at their time like they had to go
through hollywood
yeah they had to create like for comedy
they had to create
jokes that were for mainstream america
that are kind of selloutish right some
of them had to sell out
yeah the accents and all that stuff or
the
the crappy character arcs just to book a
thing that's what i mean i respect like
those people like bobby lee and and like
dante
bosco you know who's been working for so
long and he had to
uh battle every asian that's at the
audition for the one
yeah it's a different role yeah we can
all go to
an audition and maybe multiple of us
would get booked
or there's multiple opportunities you
know but before there was just literally
one
what was cool was dante's role he made
it cool to be him
right right oh he was like the coolest
kid in the movie he was a cool
every other kid was like i want to be i
don't know what he is but i want to be
like that
yeah they didn't even know you know what
yeah i know he was asian
they didn't know i think asians knew but
other people don't i did it they just go
what is this guy i don't even know i
thought he was a native american
yeah that makes sense last week what he
was i was just like cool i had a crush
on him oh you did
yeah and then did you see him again you
were like
no i mean i guess like the first time
meeting him i i remembered when i was a
little girl and like i thought about her
and how she would like internally like
how she's feeling
meeting roofio and i'm like oh how cool
and then now every time we see each
other he still looks good
for his age if i saw angelina jolie and
i'm a grandpa and she's a grandma
i'd still be like oh let me get my young
joe dreams
like become a reality did you cut her
titties off though
i still lick it cut her titties off you
mean because she had cancer
yeah oh okay hey don't make it all sad
like that
i don't know i still lick it like i just
it's the imagination that counts
you'll you'll lick where you think the
phantom nipple would yeah
i would lick where where i thought it
was she's like no a little bit
a little bit lower oh i thought it was
bigger sorry well on a brighter note
before someone brought it down
with the whole cancer thing i've been
loving oxyclean max force
because i've been starting jiu jitsu way
more and you guys know me like any
little touch on my nose i bleed like
crazy
so i get blood all over my ghee and the
ghee is white
and it looks weird when it has weird
stains and you show up to class so i've
been using
the spray and you spray it on and you
leave it overnight and when you wash
it really takes it out so it's one of
the best stain removers i've ever used
and it's really convenient it tackles
the toughest dried end stains with five
types of stain fighters to remove
grease oil grass blood soil clay
food and drink stains at the first time
so i've been using it on a lot of
taika's clothes when he spills
his chocolate ice cream all over me so i
really like it
make sure you go check that out clay as
well that's crazy so if you guys don't
want um
like a red tie-dye karate ghee
all the blood make sure you you try
oxiclean max force for yourself to work
your magic with oxiclean go to
oxiclean.com
maxforce1 to get a coupon for one dollar
off baby
woohoo nice that's that's great at
target you know when you have that
big purchase yeah get a couple dollars
off from the things you're saying
it does add up are you an extreme
couponer
i am i'm not my girlfriend is though
she's like yeah she's very we use the
target app and stuff we scan everything
first before we
becomes a game yeah for her it does
sometimes i feel like
it's fake you know what i mean like you
know when you're like you go to the like
you go to vons right
and then they're like you get like a
bottle of water and they're like dude
card
and this is the bottle of water it's
like five bucks or something i don't
know i'm just making it up
and i'm like no and they're like i love
when they
pull they pull out their bonds card
right and they go they go and it goes
five dollars and it goes down to like a
dollar fifty i'm like
what the [ __ ] i'm like is this real
savings or you just bumped it up to five
bucks
just like a feel like things just so it
could feel like saving uh i see what
you're saying
i'm like probably i don't know if these
are real well that's from the grocery
store themselves but like actual like
coupons and stuff that's like from the
company
like the brand itself oh my goodness i'm
just giving you like right now like the
brand is
all right right right discounts yeah but
the card thing i love that all the
coupons are in the apps now though i
don't have to cut [ __ ] out
like at in the time yeah and the target
out you scan everything
or like vons it'll like actually tell
you there's a coupon there so you just
scan it and then
they give you a background you know what
i missed though i really miss being a
little girl at the grocery store and
grabbing the the coupons from the things
oh yeah those things oh the red pull it
out but what about behind the receipt
when you look
behind the receipt and then there's
printed don't [ __ ] go to cvs man that
shit's like forever
it's like this long that's wasteful
still it's like a chinese scroll
it is all their laws and stuff that's
the first time i ever saw what like a
collaboration was because you go to like
ralph's right
and you flip it over but it's like
coupons to the local car wash
oh collaboration oh
car wash ralph's cross promotion and
[ __ ]
because i would take thirsty and throw
it away mom's no no no no keep it if you
say five bucks the car wash well
speaking of collabs you guys brought up
like off camera how you were recently
thinking about the last time that you
guys did a collab for that music video
yes
that's gotta be like 30 years ago it was
about 30 years ago
we drove 90 minutes it was eight years
ago
90 minutes casey and i were we just
started
like we just started dating around that
time in case he was filming it
yeah casey he filmed it i ended up
asking him to
direct another music video that i did
because of that the whole time
um but yeah we did a justin bieber
parody
did we record vocals i did we did like
together
in the studio oh i don't know or maybe i
said oh i was in that one yes done
a pig or something and then david david
was a cow yeah
or or chicken he was no he was a chicken
oh he was he's a chicken
he was a chicken yeah yeah that's the
first time i heard him sing as well
and y'all as well that was fun it was
very hot that day
there was a lot of hay i remember
because we were in costumes it was crazy
inside and stuff that was a fun video
i know i remember booking that ranch and
that was like the first time we had to
pay
how much was it i don't know i don't
know
it was crazy like back in those days
like the skits that we did
the production that we had for like zero
dollars
we were very resourceful as a producer
thank you smashed as a producer like it
was it was pretty cool like all the
projects were able to do
it's pretty cool how like we pulled off
so much stuff just
i actually don't know how to work with
money now
because i'm so used to doing things
without yeah that's [ __ ] good
yeah i'm just like wait who do you hire
for this he's like well can't
this guy just do it like he's already
doing four things i don't know
he's already doing what he's already
slammed maybe he'll do another maybe
he'll do another game for free
spoilers i like that we that there is
money now
that i can um even to people who do
expect to do it for free
you know if you give them 50 to 100 to
for for their time and stuff i feel like
we're helping build that next generation
because we didn't have the money to
necessarily do it in our beginning days
yeah for sure you say we just do it for
for free and like we'll drive out who
cares yeah
someone that opened my eyes recently is
um i didn't think he would ever respond
but you know ronnie chang the stuff yeah
yeah
i love him so i started talking to him
and we actually talk a lot is he
australian
or british uh he's like singaporean
something like that like malaysian
so he has a weird accent but he's really
cool but um
you mean he has a singaporean accent oh
no okay well i can't hear his accent
it's like malaysian a little bit can you
ask him can you say ryan
let me just google it but let's ask him
malaysian anyways um so like
when i was talking to him i was like
when my first reach out to him was like
hey man i really like your stuff you're
like you're really funny unlike a lot of
the other asians
why did you say that i was like yeah i
was just being honest
and then uh and he goes oh man i
appreciate yourself in the bunch yeah
never
well i don't even qualify cause i have a
netflix special so we
we started talking and then one thing
that i really liked about what he said
because i used to talk hella [ __ ] about
a lot of other asian comedians
well he's he thinks that people have to
pave the way
for what you've done he's like if it's
not for them
if people didn't have bad sets it's
never going to evolve to get to where
you're at
so he never looks at any other asian
american he doesn't look down on them
yeah like the way i did huh so he
schooled you schooled me yeah because he
was like he's like if you think about
even like martin scorsese right how many
bad italian directors came out that you
never heard of to develop martin
scorsese
so martin scorsese isn't the first
italian filmmaker he's just
the one that actually came up and i'm
like oh [ __ ] see hater i never thought
of it that way so after that i started
liking crazy rich asians a little more
so is he gonna come on the show or what
oh man he's hard so
with with the whole pandemic corona
thing it already makes it hard but he
shoots the daily show with trevor noah
so i think trevor noah i think thursday
through sunday
he's in new york for sure oh yeah that's
when we filmed and it is when we film so
that's the tough part but i think it'd
be worth it to have a special day
official edition yeah um but it's just
right now it's
he because when the minute he saw how
crazy it was in america he went straight
to australia he's i'm i'd rather be
stuck here and they're completely on
lockdown he made the wrong call i think
he's back now
oh he's just bouncing around that's what
i'm asking completely locked down yeah
but that
opened up my eyes where like i was like
i like that perspective you like
i see why people like you have to have a
william hung first before you have an aj
rafael you know
[Laughter]
i own my career that's the williams
you